Alhamdulillah.
My special elders and my dear brothers
and sisters, I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings. Assalamu
alaykum. May peace, mercy, and blessings
of Allah subhananaa tala be honor of
you.
It's a pleasure for
me to be in Tanzania especially in the
city of Darus Salam. It is my first
visit to this country. I was there in
Zanzibar for the last couple of days and
now I'm in Dar Salam. It was my desire
to visit Tanzania and finally Allah has
made it possible. Alhamdulillah. The
topic of this evening's talk of mine is
what is the purpose of our
lives?
What how many times have we thought of
this of this question? What is the
purpose of our
lives? What is the purpose of our
existence? Why are we
here? What are we doing here? Let us
analyze today from the people over here
in this
auditorium. How many of you have ever
thought before what is the purpose of
our lives? Please raise your hand. How
many of us have thought before what is
the purpose of our lives? Or maybe about
20%. Okay, about 15 to 20% have
thought. Is it a requirement for us to
know what is the purpose of our life? Is
it a must?
I will give you a few
examples to make you realize whether it
is a requirement or not. Once there was
a person who came at a crossroad and he
asked a passer by where does this road
go? So the passer by asked him where do
you want to go? He says anywhere. So the
passer by replied then it makes no
difference which road you take because
the person had no goal. He had no
destination. So what different does it
make which road he takes? So why is he
asking where does the road go? This
person had no goal, no
destination. Let me give you one more
example of a person who has no
goal. Once the builder, he lays the
foundation of making a building. So
someone asks him how many
stories is the building? He says I don't
know what is the total area of the
building. He says I don't know. So
imagine a person lays the foundation of
the building doesn't know how many story
building it is doesn't know what is the
total area no goal. So in our
life if we don't know the purpose we are
like that passes by and we are like the
builder. Let me give you one more
example. Once a person asks his
neighbor, your dog, he always chases
cars and vehicles, I'm wondering, will
he ever catch up with any
car? So his neighbor
replies, you are thinking, will he ever
catch up with any car? I'm thinking what
will he do if he catches up with the
car? Even if he catches up with the car,
what will the dog do? So this means a
purposeless goal. His goal is to catch
up with the car. But what will he do
after catching up with the car? So this
is the second example of purposeless
goal. For
example, many of us we are doing
graduation. When we ask him what will
you do after graduation? I don't know.
Why do you want to become a graduate? I
don't know. So his goal is to become a
graduate. But he has no purpose.
This is the second example
of having a goal without purpose.